many people come in they say how can i
start and i've got this one eight kalan
and i said well start with fruit trees
and around each fruit tree make a garden
you know so you're watering those fruit
trees and that water will also go for
that garden so around each fruit tree
you have like a a two and a half meter
diameter circle where you have
tapioca the marawi kalinga kappa you
have drumstick you have a papaya you
have a couple of bananas and maybe you
have pumpkins that go out so instead of
trying to you know irrigate the whole
field and take care of a whole field
you've actually got say 20 or 30 circles
that you take care of and you could even
put a drip on each circle because you
have to be practical you know this is a
very romantic
idea that we're presenting but it's
grounded in utter pragmatism and reality